yo you've uh recently been uh in a
mix-up online with uh adam
what happened with uh with the adam
thing obviously you know
like i just
i don't got a problem saying the truth
but it seemed like every time i say the
truth people get mad i hit him up i told
him i'm like that's um well it's funny
because t-rel was at my show and he was
like i gotta go cause i gotta go
interview ralphie
yeah he called me but i mean he text me
and then i called me so whatever that
day was t-rel was here that day doing an
interview with me so
he takes me a long paragraph telling my
smile you're gonna kill me you're not
caught i mean that's you know i don't do
all the texts right right right right if
you take me like that's like my [ __ ]
text me i'm gonna look like
you're gonna have to call me six times
now because now it's just right like you
know what i'm saying but
no i called me an answer so i just left
like that but uh not adam i told that
[ __ ] like i tried my g say he to homie
so
if you the homie and you say you [ __ ]
with us how you [ __ ] with us why it's
been so long it's like all right so
three months after draco died i hit him
up like [ __ ] damn they like you know
what i'm saying like can i pay for some
promo like [ __ ] [ __ ] you the homies if
you don't help me you're supposed to
just be posting it so obviously i feel
like you ain't doing nothing so you're
saying essentially three months after he
died no not even that i'm just going
crazy no no but like you're putting out
so much music and and with your gripe i
made a pop album that went number 25.
it's essentially
why why am i not seeing my stuff being
promoted on unless you keep laughing
everybody so i just like i hit him up
i'm like all right
you uh i said how much do i got to pay
you to get like some weekly promo he's
like oh you ain't got to pay me it's
good
all right good luck and appreciate it if
he would have did it you know what i'm
saying good looking
he never said that so then
i think it was like april or something
i'm like yeah what's up like you don't
[ __ ] you y'all anti-sting team man no
jumper you know i'm saying like what
y'all [ __ ] with the homies or something
you're like oh well
he he hit me up my dm on twitter like oh
we got to clear something up what's your
number i sent him my number didn't text
me don't hit me up so now i caught i
mean now it's two weeks later i'm just
like [ __ ] you're there's a hug yeah i'm
saying like i ain't gonna keep asking
you for to pay reminds you i gotta ask
you to pay for bromo you know yeah i
know he doesn't uh
personally run that page no he responded
to me i hit him up on adam 22 no i mean
i mean
[Laughter]
there's a lot going on on that neck man
yeah yeah man but not like i was saying
uh
i hit him up so then he you know saying
he said what he said i said what i said
well hopefully i mean i know um ain't
nothing like i just said what i said i
need
i know it's nothing like serious but i
just know that adam obviously had a lot
of love for your brother and uh i feel
like he just got people near i mean he
literally he kind of
said like they fake bullying i'm like
you know baby baby on me when i be
posting long live the ruler he's got
he's got a lot of [ __ ] uh like that
no i mean that ig page the quote unquote
no jump right g page is ran by like four
different people yeah but no jumpers
kind of like
really stink team shoreline greedo fans
you know what i'm saying you got a l.a
based podcast why do you think all your
comments are stink team you know what
i'm saying you post somebody that we
don't like you get a hundred stink team
comments and arrest bots you know what
i'm saying so for you to act like you
don't have to
play a role with this [ __ ] draco gone
you know i'm saying basically you don't
need this yeah you know what i'm saying
so for your platform you already built
that um
and his oh well i was the only one that
talked about y'all yes because it was
the only one i gave you a platform so
when draco went to jail he was the topic
of your your platform you know i'm
saying don't make it seem like you were
the only one talking about you only talk
about what's to talk about that's what
you do you're a podcast you get
understanding yeah i think he was
probably the biggest
to talk about it but you know shout out
to like guys like you know my guy rose
clans vic like there was a lot of people
who was um definitely
kind of documented
like probably twice you know i'm saying
we was in trial for three years and
you're saying it's like